all right let's continue with the sixth
overall pick in the draft there are our
guesses for the top five miami dolphins
after going from three to twelve now at
six miles simmons what do they do
i believe they picked devonta smith i
think they're going to reunite to attack
available and devante smith those two
did things that were really good at
alabama i think that the miami dolphins
want to keep getting speed there down
there on their offensive side of the
ball and i think obviously smith a
heisman trophy winner he's got that he
can provide that and you know he's
already got a little bit of built-in
chemistry with tua so i think that'd be
a good pick for him
most of these
are
educated guesses or complete guesses
this one is more educated guests than
complete guests
i think they go
jaylen waddle with the sixth and one
based on the board as we've constructed
it i think they go jaylen waddle there's
gonna be the opportunity to trade out
quarterback's still there you've got mac
jones still there i've got trade land
still there i think they go jail and
water and jaylen waddle i think gets the
edge over to march chase because chase
opted out last year and i think that's
going to hurt him i wish that wasn't the
case i hope that's not the case but i
think it's going to be jaylen waddle
sixth overall to miami dolphins that's
just my gut feeling
okay well i mean it was last year that
everybody thought that jerry judy was
going to be the first alabama wide
receiver off the board and it ends up
being henry ruggs and i think we still
don't know if that was or was not a
mistake maybe you know we will see
um in this upcoming season but uh for
the next pick with the lions at number
seven overall i feel like if there's
still a qb on the board right here this
is definitely a place where they could
trade out um because the lions are
rebuilding they need to be able to get
guys and unless they think mac jones is
their quarterback of the future and is
going to be somebody better than jared
goff then they would pick him i don't
necessarily know if that's the case but
in this scenario where we're not trading
picks uh i would say that the lions get
somebody like jamar chase because he is
such a big play receiver right now their
wide outs are
very iffy kind of at best i mean kenny
gallaudet is gone jones is gone so they
need somebody to be a big play guy and i
think that he can come in and he can
probably be that he made all kinds of
plays with joe burrow down there when
they won the national championship
hey i
i actually have the top two
quarterbacks or not two but i have two
left i have trey lance and justin fields
left i don't think chris spielman former
ohio state great i don't think he's
gonna be able to resist justin fields
there if he's there at seven
and i think spielman's got a lot more
juice than people realize jared goff is
definitely a short-term thing
they they traded for him in part because
number one they don't have a veteran guy
number two they picked up an extra first
round pick to do so they didn't get two
ones in a three
four matthew stafford they got a one and
a three for stafford and a one to take
on that contract i think they take
justin fields in that spot miles
i like that if he's still there yeah i
think that that would make sense because
i feel like he's a different type of
quarterback than a jared goff and i
think he maybe might fit what anthony
lin would construct for an offense a
little bit better than a jared goff
would just because justin fields has
that mobility uh for eight i kind of go
back and forth for the panthers between
an offensive lineman and kyle pitts who
is still on the board especially because
the panthers
just
man they don't have anybody who can
really make plays at tight end at least
they didn't last year but i'm gonna go
with raeshawn slater because they really
do need a tackle they have to get
somebody to come in there and uh replace
russell okung so i think if they do that
they're at least setting up sam darnold
to have a better chance at success and
better protection and you really want to
be able to evaluate sam darnold this
year because if it turns out that he's
no good then you know that you're going
to be in that quarterback derby again
next year and if he doesn't have good
protection you might not be able to
evaluate him properly
they're going to be tempted to take trey
lance at eight
but
i
i i think that they're going to go with
somebody to help sam darnold be as good
as he can be curtis samuel left via free
agency jamar chase is still available
coach
matt rule said we now can take the best
player who's there when we pick and
jamar chase in my mind is that guy so
i'll go chase it eight to the panthers
all right that makes plenty of sense uh
at the broncos number nine so that's
where either the broncos probably could
trade back if matt jones is still on the
board or
i would they could do what i think
they're going to do and take it why
wouldn't they take jones take jones yes
don't say yes that's exactly what i'm
going to say yeah they're going to take
mack jones because i think that they
probably would evaluate him as being
better than drew locke and i mean you
know what drew lock has made some plays
he's shown some traits but i think the
experience that mack jones can bring
into that program from being from
alabama from playing in the pro system
he might be somebody that can supplant
drew lock day one as a starting
quarterback and so if you are able to
get your quarterback of the future i
think that that's something that they're
going to want to do it because drew
locke
george payton doesn't have any
allegiance to him he didn't draft him so
that's why i think that at that point
that's what they would do
i'll go trey lance same reason it's just
lance is the guy who's left for me jones
was the guy who's left for you they've
been looking for an upgraded quarterback
i think if they don't get a quarterback
in round one that's when they end up
doing a deal for teddy bridgewater
there's a chance they would do that deal
before the draft i think they want to
see how the top ten plays out who they
get in round one
and then if they don't have
a quarterback by the end of round one
before the draft continues the next day
i think they would get teddy bridgewater
i'm guessing for a fifth or sixth round
pick with carolina paying 3 million of
his salary
him getting 9 million more from the
broncos a total of 12 million and i
think he'd become most likely the
starter for 2021. all right who do you
have for
your 10th pick dallas cowboys do they
give in to the infatuation that jerry
jones has with kyle pitts
i i feel like they would really really
want to because kyle pitts is somebody
that could be really really good but
i think sometimes you have to draft for
need when your defense is as bad as the
dallas cowboys defense was so i'm going
to give them patrick's retain the second
i think he's a really good cornerback i
think he can develop into the type of
guy that they need on the outside to
pair opposite digs and if you do that
then yeah you know it's not necessarily
going to be the same offensively but i
think they have a good enough offense
already that even though you probably
want a draft best player available i can
certainly see them drafting pits but i
just i feel like in this scenario
weirdly enough pitts is going to fall
out of the top 10.
they need a heart and soul of that
defense frankly and i know jalen smith
has been that to a certain extent and it
was shawn lee
they got to go best available defensive
player they have the run
of the entire defensive board this is
kind of like having the first pick in
the draft because they shouldn't be
taking an offensive player they don't
have needs on offense like they do on
defense saga markup michael parsons the
penn state linebacker although they
could go three four different ways
they'd go quiddy pay the michigan
defensive lineman they'd go caleb farley
the virginia tech corner uh but but they
got to come out of
that round one with a difference maker
on defense because they need plenty of
them if they want to get to where they
want to be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports